you know for me it's just about the
results and at the end of the day while
you know it was strange apartment was
obviously very happy that
Donald Trump was not branded a rapist um
I didn't think there should be any
liability findings so we'll pursue it
we'll pursue yeah this is a circus
atmosphere
um and having him be here would be more
of a circus and again when I said in the
summation yesterday you know range true
um holds true it's that you know what
more could these sail than I didn't do
it and he said that on the road here you
know it's hard to prove a negative Molly
so you stole my pen
prove he didn't do it how would you
prove it so you didn't do it right I
mean it's sort of where we're at so you
know it's it's very simplistic to say oh
he should have testified he had nothing
to say other than what it's already said
on the road